[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا في اخبار الساعه من
العربيه نستعرض ونرصد معكم ابرز المستجدات
ونبدا بالعناوين
ز
اوكرانيا مقاتلات تايفون
البحريه الامريكيه والبريطانيه تكشفان عن
مصادره شحنه اسلحه ايرانيه كانت متجهه الى
اليمن
دعم عسكري يستفز الصين امريكا تبيع تايوان
صواريخ وذخائر بقيمه 619 مليون دولار
مع انطلاق اجتماعي وزراء خارجيه العشرين
في نيودلهي الهند تؤكد وجود خلافات حاده
تجاه الازمات الدوليه
في مقابله خاصه مع العربيه قال وزير
الدفاع البريطاني بنوالص ان بلاده لن تمنح
اوكرانيا مقاتلات سايفون في الفتره
المقبله مشيرا الى انها تحتاج الى تدريبات
مكثفه واطقم لتدريب الطيارين الاوكرانيين
عليها وشدد والص على ان الغرب لا ينوي نشر
قوات في اوكرانيا
وبالفعل نادرا ندرك بالتاكيد انه في المدى
البعيد سيكون هذا مطلبا ضروريا
للاوكرانيين بعد الحرب ولحاجتهم للدفاع عن
انفسهم هذه مساله مهمه لكن تسليحهم
بطائرات تايفون الحربيه البريطانيه في
المدى القصير ليس ممكنا ليس بسبب المده
الزمنيه التي يحتاجها الطيار لقياده هذه
الطائرات انما الفتره الزمنيه الضروريه
للقتال على متن تلك الطائرات الحربيه فضلا
عن اطقم المسانده التي تحتاج اليها
الطائره المقاتله تشبه سياره سباق
الفورميلا والتي يجب ان يرافقها فريق من
200 شخص في غياب هؤلاء سيتعذر على الطائره
ان تظل في الاجواء لفتره طويله طبعا
بريطانيا وغيرها من البلدان الغربيه لن
تقوم بنشر قوات على الارض في اوكرانيا
قال ايضا ان مهمه بلاده هي ضمان انسحاب
القوات الروسيه من اوكرانيا مشددا على ان
بريطانيا والمجتمع الدولي مشددا على دعمهم
الاكياف وانه صلب
اعتقد انها ستذهب بعيدا لان المجتمع
الدولي والمملكه المتحده يتبنون موقفا
صلبا داعما لاوكرانيا فقد تم التاكيد
مجددا على هذا الموقف في الاونه الاخيره
من خلال تقديم دبابات غربيه هذا يثبت ان
عام 2023 لن يكون مختلفا عن عام 2022 باي
حال من الاحوال نحن مصممون على المضي قدما
في هذا الاتجاه مهمتنا ضمان انسحاب روسيا
من اوكرانيا الامر لا يتعلق بمهاجمه روسيا
او تغيير حكومتها هذا امر لا يعنينا انما
الدفاع عن اوكرانيا او مساعده الاوكرانيين
على الدفاع عن انفسهم وضمان احترام سياده
القانون في العالم وسياده الدول وهي امور
غايه في الاهميه
الى معركه بخموت الاشد حتى الان على
الساحه الاوكرانيه حيث تردد حديث عن
انسحاب اوكراني محتمل قد يغير المعادله في
الجبهه الشرقيه هذا على الاقل ما يدور في
الكواليس حيث رجح احد النواب الاوكرانيين
الانسحاب من المدينه عاجلا ام اجلا لكن
على الارض اكدت السلطات ان القوات
الاوكرانيه لا تزال تتمسك بمواقعها في
المدينه رغم التقدم الروسي والهجمات
المكثفه والقتال العنيف كما اعلنت هيئه
الاركان العامه الاوكرانيه عن تلقي هجمات
مكثفه من الجيش الروسي في مدينه باخموت من
جانب موسكو فقد اوضحت السلطات ان السيطره
على بخموت ستفتح الطرق امامها للسيطره
ايضا على منطقه
ينضم الينا مراسل العربيه رائد الاغبر
صباح الخير رائد اهلا بك يعني اخر
التحديثات الميدانيه بما يخص معركه بخموت
التي يبدو انها الاكثر دمويه حسب وصف
يفخيني رئيس ومؤسس مجموعه فاجنر
صباح الخير راويه بالفعل معركه باخموت هي
الاسخن وباتت كل يعني المنابر العالميه
تتحدث عن اخر التطورات في باخمه رغم ان
المنطقه باكملها مستعره هنا ولابد من عدم
اقفال ان مدينه دانيسكو وضواحيها تتعرض
للقصف يوميا بالامس اقل من 200 قذيفه
وصاروخ اسفرت عن اصابتين ودمار في البناء
التحتيه وسكنيه كما ان القوات الروسيه
تتقدم في عده محاور مثل المثلث الناري بين
خار كيف
سيطره اليوم قوات روسيا على مراكز جديده
ونقاط عسكريه جديده حول مدينه كوبيانس 3
كيلومترات يبتعد الجيش الروسي عن كوبيانس
محور باقمت بالفعل ما زالت المعارك محتدمه
في كل الجبهات الجبهه الشماليه هي الاهم
والاكثر سخونه بعد ان سيطرت قوات فاجنر
بلده يا قدنا تقدمت لاكمال الطوق نحو
الغرب من الشمال نحو الغرب
وتبتعد الان ثلاثه كيلومترات عن بلده
خروموفا بالفعل الطريق الى بلده بردانه
لاكمال الطوق في الناحيه الغربيه الحديث
من السلطات المحليه هنا بان القوات
الاوكرانيه خسرت ما نسبته
70% من قواتها على الارض بينما قال
مؤسس قوات فاجنر بان امدادات عسكريه بشريه
وبالاليات وصلت للقوات الاوكرانيه وان
السيطره على المدينه ليست سهله بالطريقه
التي يراها الكثير كما ان الانتقادات عادت
لتطفو على السطح ما بين مؤسس قوات فاجنر
والجيش الروسي بالفعل هناك تصريحات اليوم
الى عدم
المساس بسمعه المقاتلين في قوات باجنر
الذين تم تجنيدهم من السجون
بما يخسر روسيا على السيطره على هذه
المدينه يعني الى جانب رمزيتها والسيطره
عليها ما دورها في الامدادات العسكريه
وايضا اي مدن ستفتح لها لاحقا
راويه نعلم بان بعد عوده الجيش الاوكراني
وسيطره على عده مدن في مقاطعات مختلفه مثل
ايمان وكوبيانسكو وفي خرسون لم يحرز الجيش
الروسي اي تقدم هو اول تقدم للجيش الروسي
بعد ان يعني اعلنت تعبئه الجزئيه وباتت
القوات الروسيه يعني تزداد هنا في المنطقه
خاصه في دانيتك هو التقدم الوحيد والذي
يريد الجيش الروسي ان يضع بصمته في هذا
المحور
ويعيد الثقه بالجيش الروسي للمواطنين
الروس ربما الذين فقدوا ثقتهم بما يقدمه
الجيش الروسي في هذه العمليه العسكريه
الخاصه اذا سيطر جيش الروسي على مدينه
باقمت هذا يعني ان جيش الروسي ماض في
التقدم في السيطره على المدن الذي يقول
بانها اهداف لها اهداف سياسيه لموسكو
ومعنيين بالسيطره على مناطق من اجل حمايه
المواطنين الروس الذين يقطنون في اوكرانيا
على سبيل المثال في دانيال اذا سيطره
الجيش الروسي على هذا يعني ان الطريق
ستكون مفتوحه امام امام المدن الكبرى
وامام يعني حوض المياه الذي
يحتبسه الجيش الاوكراني خلف مدينه
خلفك والمدن الكبرى خلف مدينه مخ شكرا
جزيلا لك قراءه الاخبار مراسل العربيه من
دنيا
هجمات المسيرات التي وصلت الى العمق
الروسي شكل التطورا نوعيا في حرب اوكرانيا
التصعيد حرب المسيرات طرح جدلا حول
الاسباب وطبيعه الاهداف فتراوحت تقديرات
خبراء عسكريين بين نظريتين الاولى
تعمدت شن هجمات
موسكو ومدى استعداد الدفاعات الروسيه
للتعامل مع هجمات نشطه ومكثفه تقع في اكثر
من موقع بشكل متزامن وراء خبراء ان هذه
الفرضيه انصحت فسوف تعني استعداد اكياف
لتوسيع هجمات مماثله في المستقبل النظريه
الثانيه تشير الى ان الاهداف التي حلقت
نحوها المسيرات لا تظهر طبيعه النيات
الاوكرانيه من الهجمات ما يرجح ان يكون
الهدف الاساسي هو اثاره الزعار بين
المواطنين الروس وتاكيد قدره التقنيات
الاوكرانيه على الوصول الى عمق المدن
الروسيه حول هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا من
دبي الدكتور رياض قهوجي الكاتب والباحث في
شؤون الامن والدفاع اهلا بك معنا دكتور
رياض يعني
الهجمات المسيره الاوكرانيه
اي نظريه برايك هي الارجح هل هدفها فقط
الترويع المواطنين الروس من خلال وصولها
الى قرب العاصمه موسكو ام اختبار الدفاعات
الروسيه ومدى جاهزيتها
لا اعتقد ان النظريه الاولى هي الاقرب
يعني لا تشن
عمليه وهجوم بهذا الشكل فقط لاختبار
الدفاعات الدفاعات معروفه
وبالتالي
اوكرانيا تريد ان تطور قدرتها على القصف
الاستراتيجي في العمق الروسي
للرد بالمثل يعني روسيا اليوم تخطئ
اوكرانيا
لقصف استراتيجي استراتيجيه حرب استنزاف
لاجبارها واخضاع اوكرانيا لارادتها اخرين
تريد اليوم ان تطور قدراتيها لتمتلك
القدره على ايضا
اخضاع روسيا لحرب استنزاف من جانبها عبر
قصف مواقع استراتيجيه تحديدا منشات
النفطيه في العنق الروسي وكلما
موقع اقرب لموسكو كلما كان وقعه اكبر على
معنويات الروس والقياده في موسكو طيب
الهجمات المسيره بالطائرات المسيره هي
التي اتجهت الى شبه جزيره القرم تحديدا
نحن نعلم القرم كم هي مهمه وهي خط احمر
بالنسبه للروس ونتذكر التصريح ديمتري الذي
قال ان الهجوم على القرم سيعني قيام
القيامه فعليا هل هذه شراره ربما
لهجمات اخرى اكبر وتوسع لهذه الحرب
لا يعني اوكرانيا تعدت هجمات القرم ليست
المره الاولى صحيح بشكل للمره الاولى
وبالتالي سنشهد المزيد من هذه الهجمات
ولكن القرم تحديدا دكتور رياض
اعرف اعرف يعني هي
جزء اساسي وجزء رئيسي من الاستراتيجيه
المضاده الاوكرانيه اليوم يعني الاتجاه
نحو الجنوب والتركيز على الجبهه الجنوبيه
هو هدفه
الوصول للقرن
اكثر من مره ان هدف استراتيجي لاوكرانيا
هو استعاده القرم وبالتالي هي
المجتمع الدوليه لا تعترف
بضم روسيا لهذه الكرم وبالتالي لا تزال
تعتبرها جزء من اراضي الاوكرانيه وبالتالي
هي جزء من ساحه المواجهه القائمه اليوم
وحتى النيتو يعني وامريكا مساعدات
لاوكرانيا
هناك بعض الصواريخ التي تقدم لاوكرانيا
ضمن شروط الا تستخدم في ضرب الاراضي الرو
انما الكرم لا تعتبره امريكا جزء من
الاراضي الروسيه وبالتالي سنشهد المزيد من
هذه العمليات طالما ان اوكرانيا لا تزال
تعتبر ان الكرم هدف اساسي لها لاستعادته
بالحديث عن هذه المواجهات الان مواقف
للشولز
وقف تسليم الاسلحه لاوكرانيا ليست طريق
نحو انشاء السلام وبالتالي الغرب ماضن في
تسليح اوكرانيا الى اي مدى ذلك يمكن برايك
ان يقضي على اي فرص للحوار والمفاوضات على
الاقل بالاشهر القليله القادمه
انا برايي الشخصي لا مجال الحوار اليوم لا
تزال لغه السلاح والحرب هي الاعلى هي
الطاغيه
سيكون سيمضي بعض الوقت قبل ان يكون
الطرفان جاهزان لاي مفاوضات الان المواقف
هي واضحه
وامريكا عازمان ويقدمان المزيد من الاسلحه
لاوكرانيا القياده الاوكرانيه تستعد لهجوم
كبير في الربيع المقبل
روسيا ايضا من جانبها تحضر او بدات هجوم
منذ فتره وبالتالي لغه الحرب لا تزال هي
الطاغيه والاساسيه
للوقت الراهن
شكرا جزيلا لك الدكتور رياض قهوجي الكاتب
والباحث في شؤون الامن والدفاع
ما بين اكبر اقتصادين في العالم خلافات
شتى لكن ما يدور حول اوكرانيا امر مفصلي
بالنسبه لامريكا وعليه فان اربعه مسؤولين
امريكيين اكدوا ان الولايات المتحده
تتواصل مع حلفائها المقربين بشان احتمال
فرض عقوبات اقتصاديه جديده على الصين
عقوبات ستنهاال على راس بيكين اذا ما جزمت
واشنطن بان الصين قدمت دعما عسكريا لروسيا
في اوكرانيا وافق مصادر مطلعه فان اداره
الرئيس جو بايدن بدات في جسي نبض الحلفاء
حول فرض عقوبات شملت اتصالات غير رسميه
على مستوى الموظفين ودبلوماسيين لحشد
الدعم من مختلف البلدان ولا سيما مجموعه
الدول السبع الثريه ففي الاونه الاخيره
قالت واشنطن تعتزم تزويد روسيا بالاسلحه
لكنها نافذ ذلك وما بين العقوبات
الامريكيه ودعم الصيني لروسيا انباء تشي
بان تقديم المساعدات المميته
يقتل معها العلاقه بين البلدين وبينما
تبحث امريكا معاقبه الصين روسيا من جانبها
تطور مواجهه امريكا فقد افادت المجله
التابعه لوزاره الدفاع الروسيه ان موسكو
تعمل على تطوير استراتيجيه عسكريه من نوع
جديد باستخدام الاسلحه النوويه لمواجهه
عدوان امريكي محتمل مشيره الى ان موسكو
ستكون مستعده اذا لزم الامر لنشر ترسانتها
النوويه الضخمه كما اضاف المقال المنشور
في مجله الدفاع الروسيه ان واشنطن قلقه من
فقدان هيمنتها على العالم ولذلك اعدت على
ما يبدو خططا لضرب روسيا
قالت وزيره الخارجيه الالمانيه انالينا
بيربوك ان اوكرانيا يجب ان تحدد بنفسها
شروط السلام مع روسيا ومنها قرار عوده
القرم الى روسيا مشيره الى ان برلين لن
تقدم نصائح لكياف في هذا الشان كما شددت
ايضا على استمرار دعم بلادها لاوكرانيا
بين غالبيه سكان الدنمارك معارضتهم ارسال
مقاتلات الى اوكرانيا في استطلاع اجراه
المعهد التحليلي الدنماركي بمشاركه 1013
شخصا ابدى 18% فقط من المستطلعين موافقتهم
على ارسال المقاتلات بينما عرض 60% ذلك
الامر
ويعتقد ان 41% من المستطلعين انه اذا بدا
الدول الاخرى في نقل المقاتلات الى
اوكرانيا فيجب على الدنمارك ان تحذو حذو
ها ننتقل الان لنتابع كلمه المستشار
الالماني
اولا كان له عده مواقف حول الصين حيث دعا
الصين لا ترسل اسلحه لروسيا
وكان تحدث قبل ذلك
عن
استمرار الدعم الالماني والغربي لاوكرانيا
وبانه تقديم الدعم او عدم تقديم الدعم
لاوكرانيا سيشجع المعتدي ويقصد بذلك روسيا
اذا نشاهد في كلمه امام مجلس
النواب الالماني
حيث يقول شورت بانه يشعر بخيبه امل تجاه
عدم استعداد الصين لادانه الحرب في
اوكرانيا
اذا نكتفي بهذا القدر من هذه الصور
القادمه من برلين
نشرتنا مستمره فيها بعض الفاصل
بعد تكرارها في عشرات المدارس ظاهره تسنيم
الطالبات في ايران تقلق العالم
اهلا بكم من جديد كشفت البحريه الامريكيه
عن مصادره شحنه اسلحه ايرانيه غير شرعيه
في 23 من فبراير الماضي بالتعاون مع
البحريه البريطانيه في خليج عمان مؤكده
على ان القارب الايراني المصادر كان يحمل
على متنه صواريخ باليستيا وصواريخ موجهه
مضاده للدبابات تشبه صواريخ قناه الروسيه
ونقل البيان عن براد كوبر قائد القياده
المركزيه للقوات البحريه الامريكيه
والاسطول الخامس ان هذه السابعه عمليه
مصادره لاسلحه او مخدرات في الاشهر الثلاث
الماضيه ومثال اخر على النشاط الايراني
البحري الدار الاخرى في التزايد في
المنطقه وفي مقابلاته الخاصه مع العربيه
اعرب وزير الدفاع البريطاني بمواليس عن
قلقه من ضلوع ايران في تزويد الحوثيين
بالاسلحه وتهديدها للامن والاستقرار
بالمنطقه واكد واليس ان ايران تتحمل
المسؤوليه لتزويدها الحوثيين بالاسلحه
هذا امر يثير قلقا بالغا طلوع ايران في
الاحداث الجاريه في اليمن يزعزع الاستقرار
ولا مصلحه لاي طرف فيه فهو لا يفيد
الحوثيين وبالتاكيد لا يفيد اي طرف لكنه
يمثل ايضا تهديدا للامن والاستقرار في
العالم انتم هنا في السعوديه بعض من هذه
الدخائر وهم يقولون ان من اطلقها الحوثيون
لكن الشخص الذي يسلح الحوثيين يتحمل ذات
المسؤوليه
وفي شان ايراني اخر حثت الخارجيه
الامريكيه ايران على التحقيق فيها هجمات
تسميم طالبات وهي ظاهره يتخوف الايرانيون
من اتساعها بعد مودي ثلاثه اشهر على رصد
اول حاله تسمم فيما ترفض الاجهزه المسؤوله
تحديد الاسباب او نوعيه المواد التي تتسبب
بحالات الاختناق بالمدارس
المشهد لم يختلف كثيرا عن الاحتجاجات التي
اندلعت اثر مقتل مهسى امين في ايران فسيرت
الاسعاف لم تعد تنقل جرح الاصابات الداميه
وانما فتيات يبكين توعكا فجائيا اصابهن او
يعانين من ضعف العضلات والخمول والغثيان
لساعات او يعانين من حالات اختناق وفي
احدث موجه تسمم تعرضت طالبه من سبع مدارس
في مدينه اردبيل ومن ثلاث مدارس اخرى في
العاصمه الى تسمم اثرار رش نوع من الرذاذ
يتكون من غاز النيتروجين الذي يستخدم في
الصناعه او كسماد زراعي ونشرت مقاطع عده
لاحتجاجات اولياء الطالبات المصابات
وقالوا ان المدرسه تتصل بنا وتطلب ان ناخذ
بناتنا دون ان تعطينا معلومات اخرى
وفي هذه الموجه الاخيره من مسلسل الارهاب
البيولوجي ينتظر الاهالي كلمه تفسر ما
الذي يجري حينما يرسلون في ذات اكبادهم
الى المدارس فتاره يقر مسؤولون في وزاره
الصحه بحدوث حالات تسمم لكنهم يصرون على
انها ليست بمواد كيميائيه بينما يؤكد
مسؤول اخر من ذات الجهه انه ليس فيروسا
لينتهي بالقول ان الاعداء وحدهم من يقفون
وراء كل تلك المصائب التي حلت على البلاد
وينضم الينا من لندن الباحث في الشان
الايراني عارف ناصر اهلا بك سيد عارف يعني
قضيه تصميم الطالبات بايران تم اكتشاف اول
حاله تسمم بقم
بعد شهر واحد من اندلاع الاحتجاجات بن
نوفمبر بايران ما ارتباط ذلك بتخويف الناس
بترويع الاهالي من عدم ارسالهن بناتهن الى
المدارس وبالتالي يعني التقليل من حجم
الاحتجاجات الدائره في ايران
تحيه طيبه لك والمشاهدين العربيه الكرام
الواقع بان يجب ربط هذا مسلسل هذه الاحداث
الغامضه بسياسه الغموض التي تنتهجها
وينتهجها النظام الايراني
وهي احدى التكتيكات التي يعتمد عليها
لاثاره الهلع بين المجتمع وبالتالي الدعوه
الى الرقابه الذاتيه فيما يتعلق بالمشاركه
بالاحتجاجات او ربما حتى مناوبئه النظام
اما النقطه الثانيه يجب ربط هذه الاحداث
بمسلسل اخر شهدتها ايران وهي ربما رش
النسابي بالحمض او الاسيد او ماء النار
كما يعرف وهي ظاهره بدات ايضا من المدير
الدينيه المتشدده دينيا
سيما قم واصفهان
وغيرها
وراح ضحيه هذا المسلسل عام 2014
والاعوام التي تلت هذا العام عده كثيرات
في في ايران لذلك انا اعتقد بانه
حينها ارتبط هذا الموضوع ايضا بحرف
الافكار العامه عن قضايا مثل الدولار
وربما ارتفاع اسعار البنزين وغيرها لذلك
انا اعتقد بان هذا المسلسل من من استهداف
النساء هو نتائج
ربما عمل استخباراتي ايراني هدفه بالدرجه
الاساس حرف الافكار العامه من ما يجري
ويحدث
السياسيه او الصعيد الاقتصادي ولكن سيد
عارف يعني تنصت السلطات من المسؤوليه واضح
جدا يعني وزاره الصحه الايرانيه تقول بان
السم المستخدم خفيف جدا وليس من اختصاصنا
حتى التحقيق بذلك ايضا لم يقدم الى الان
اي تصريح من النظام الايراني يعني حتى لو
كان هناك احتجاجات ضد هذا النظام ولكنه
حتى الان هو الحاكم وعليه تبرير او تفسير
ما يحصل
وهذا ان دل على شيء يدل بان النظام
الايراني هو الضالع بهذه
مسلسل الاحداث التي نشهدها
بثواب المدارس او ربما حتى بالشوارع
وبالتالي
ان دل على شيء يدل ايضا بان النظام
الايراني يريد ربما بث الهلع بين المجتمع
الايراني للوصول الى اجندته عمليا نحن اذا
ما غارنا نوعيه التعامل مثلا مع محسن
شكاري الذي اعدم بتهمه الحرابه وتم
التحقيق معه ربما بفتره لا تتجاوز العشرين
يوم من الحدث حتى الاعدام بينما مثلا
باحداث اخرى كمثلا رش الاسيد الان منذ
2014 وحتى الان ولم يصدر اي حكم يدين اي
جهه من الجهات وهذا ان دل على شيء يدل بان
النظام الايراني هو من يقف وراء هذه مسلسل
هذه الاحداث
المعارضه الايرانيه وصفت ما يحصل بانه
اسلوب ممنهج من النظام الايراني وبانه
يذكرها باسلوب بوكو حرام بنيجيريا وايضا
حركه طالبان الافغانيه في التعامل مع
النساء تحديدا
يعني بالفعل اذا ما راينا بان الذين الان
ربما اذا ما تابعنا وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي نجد بان الذين يدافعونها عن هذا
المنهج هم مجموعه من الذين شاركوا
بمليشيات متطرفه سواء في العراق او في
سوريا او في مناطق اخرى وعادوا الى ايران
وبالتالي جاؤوا محملين بافكار متطرفه
بافكار ربما يريدون تطبيقها في المجتمع
الايراني وبالتالي اعتقد بان هذا الامر
ايضا يدل بان هنالك موجد تطرف ديني
عائده من هذا الجو المشحون في منطقه الشرق
الاوسط عائده الى ايران وبالتالي ظهرت
وربما تصل الى مرحله حتى سلطات لا تستطيع
السيطره على مثل هذه التحركات الخطيره
المتطرفه دينيه شكرا جزيلا لك من لندن
الباحث في الشان الايراني عارف ناصر
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
الحكومه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
اكد وزير الخارجيه الهندي وجود خلافات
حاده في الراي داخل مجموعه العشرين بشان
نزاعات الدوليه والازمات العالميه وقال
خلال افتتاح اجتماع وزراء خارجيه مجموعه
العشرين ان العالم ينتظر ايجاد ارضيه
مشتركه لحل النزاعات ومواجهه ازمات المناخ
وهشاشه سلاسل التوريد والديون
نشرتنا مستمره فيها بعض الفاصل
ايطاليا تتهم اليونان بالتسبب في غرق
قوارب المهاجرين والاخير
في مقابله خاصه مع العربيه وزير الدفاع
البريطاني يؤكد ان بلاده لن تمنح اوكرانيا
مقاتلات تايفو
البحريه الامريكيه والبريطانيه تكشفان عن
مصادره شحنه اسلحه ايرانيه كانت متجهه الى
اليمن
دعم عسكري يستفز الصين امريكا تبيع تايوان
صواريخ وذخائر بقيمه 619 مليون دولار
مع انطلاق اجتماعي وزراء خارجيه العشرين
في نيودلهي الهند تؤكد وجود خلافات حاده
تجاه الازمات الدوليه
اهلا بكم من جديد فمن وزير الدفاع
البريطاني بنوالس عمق العلاقات مع
السعوديه واكد واليس في مقابله خاصه مع
العربيه ان العلاقات مع دول الخليج لها
اهميه قصوى بالنسبه لبريطانيا على كافه
المستويات
كانت جيده للغايه بقيت كذلك على مدى عقود
حتى قبل ان يبدا التعاون بين بلدينا في
مجال الفضاء والدفاع انا امثل شركه تعمل
في مقاطعه الانتخابيه هي شركه سعوديه
مصنعه لافضل انواع الاشممه التي تباع في
السعوديه هي موجوده منذ ثلاثينيات القرن
الماضي العلاقه الثنائيه قويه وعميقه
للغايه ولمنطقه الخليج اهميه قصوى بالنسبه
للمملكه المتحده على كافه الصعود
الاستراتيجيه منها او الاقتصاديه هذا يخدم
رفاهنا وهو امر ايجابي لقد عقدت اجتماعي
الثالث مع الامير خالد بن سلمان والتقيته
من قبل في لندن وكذلك هنا في المملكه قبل
عامين
الهيئه العامه للكنيسه الاسرائيليه
بالقراءه التمهيديه على مشروع فرض عقوبه
الاعدام على منفذي هجمات ضد اسرائيل وذلك
باغلبيه 55 عضوا مقابل تسعه اعضاء وفي هذا
الشان اعتبرت حركه فتح القرار شرعنه للقتل
موضحه ان اسرائيل تضرب الاتفاقيات الدوليه
بعرض الحائط واولها اتفاقيه جونيف الرابعه
ونص مشروع القانون على الزام المحكمه
باعدام من يرتكب مخالفه قتل بدافع عن قومي
بهدف المس بدوله اسرائيل واشمل القانون
اعدام من يثبت تنفيذه اي عمليه تسببت
بمقتل اسرائيليين اذا قتل نفسه او ارسل او
خطط او وجه العمل
رفض المتحدث باسم وزاره الخارجيه
الامريكيه تصريحات وزير الماليه
الاسرائيلي التي دعا فيها الى محو قريه
حواره الفلسطينيه واصفا اياها بغير
المسؤوله وتحرض على العنف ودعم برايس رئيس
الوزراء الاسرائيلي بنيامين نتنياهو وغيره
من كبار المسؤولين الى التنصل علنا من
تصريحات وزير الماليه في الوقت الذي تواجه
فيه حكومه تل ابيب احتجاجات لم تحدث منذ
سنوات استخدمت خلالها الشرطه مسدسات
الصعاق ضد المتظاهرين فيما اطلق عليه يوم
التشويش
هذا وتوصل قوات الامن الاسرائيليه البحث
عن منفذ عمليه اطلاق النار التي وقعت في
حواره يوم الاحد الماضي وادت الى مقتل
مستوطنين اثنين ياتي ذلك بالتزامن مع
تنفيذ الجيش الاسرائيلي حمله اعتقالات
طالت 13 فلسطينيين في انحاء متفرقه من
الضفه الغربيه والقدس المحتله فيما يحاول
الفلسطينيون في بلده حواء اعاده الحياه
الى طبيعتها بسبب الاضرار التي لحقت
بالبيوت والمنازل والمركبات جرى حرقها على
ايدي مستوطنين اسرائيليين وينضم الينا من
رام الله مراسل العربيه خالد القاسم اهلا
بك خالد يعني تطورات التصعيد الاسرائيلي
على خلفيه حادثتي حواره وايضا اريحا
نعم في اريحا يعم الاضراب الشامل اليوم
عقب مقتل فلسطيني برصاص الجيش الاسرائيلي
يوم امس عندما حاصرت قوات كبيره من الجيش
مبنى وبدات باطلاق النار وقنابل الغاز
باتجاهي اعتقلت سته فلسطينيين كان احدهم
مصاب اعلن بعد من بعد ظهر امس بانه
ارتقى لذلك يعم الاضراب والحداد مدينه
اريحا هذا اليوم بلده حواره ما يزال
الجو فيها مشحونا رغم ان كل المحال
التجاريه على الشوارع الرئيسي مغلقه بقرار
من الجيش الاسرائيلي قوات كبيره من الجيش
تتمركز على على طول الشارع الرئيسي الذي
يمر من حواره باتجاه نابلس او
باتجاه رام الله وعمليات البحث كما ذكرت
راويه في بدايه الخبر ما تزال مستمره وراء
منفذ عمليه اطلاق النار يوم الاحد الماضي
والتي ادت الى مقتل مستوطنين اثنين وما
تبعها من احداث عنف قام بها
المستوطنون باتجاه سكان بلده حواره حيث
احرقوا عشرات المركبات
والمنازل والمنشات
الفلسطينيه حتى هذه اللحظه لم تبدا اعمال
الترميم في
المنازل التي تضررت جره التهام النيران
معظمها كما نفذ ايضا الجيش الاسرائيلي
حمله دهن واسعه في الاراضي الفلسطينيه نجم
عنها اعتقال حوالي 15 فلسطينيه من مناطق
مختلفه في الضفه الغربيه والقدس المحتله
شكرا جزيلا لك اذا من رام الله خالد
القاسم مراسل العربيه
رغم مرور اسابيع على الزلزال الذي شطر
قريه جسر الحديد الواقعه على الحدود
التركيه كما نشاهد في هذه الصوره شطرها
الى نصفين وتسبب في تصدع شديد للطريق
الرئيسي للبلده ما يزال هول الحدث عالقا
في اذهان ساكنيها مع بقاء اثار الكارثه
ترسم معالم هذه القريه
قوه الزلزال الذي ضرب جنوب تركيا يظهره
حال هذا الطريق بمدخل قريه جسر الحديد
تصدع كبير اصابه الى درجه نزوله
عن سطح الارض بحوالي متر وانزياحه ايضا
شمالا بنسبه كبيره السلطات التركيه قامت
بترميم جزء من هذا الطريق لفك العزله عن
سكان القريه الهادئه الواقعه قرب الحدود
السوريه صار يهزنا اشكال والوان يعني
ظليت حوالي
الارض طريق كان عالي عن مترين لتحت سرقتين
اكثر من مترين لتحت عن الجسر الحديد جواده
الضيعه كل نزلت على العاص
اودي البيوت كلهن بقوموا هاي الهوا
بينزلوا ويقوموا بينزلوا البيوت وبعدين
راعوا هيك فوق العاص النهر يعني راحوا
النهر 30 متر من هون هيك راحوا للنهار
سكروا النهر وبعد المويه
وعلوان يابا بيتي مو مهدود ضحك
شقيت وجعت وحريت وظليت كم سنه من دون بيت
كم سنه ضليت سويت هالبيت هذا سويته والله
ما هلالي يابا ما قعدت بيه
الى نصفين بفعل قوه الزلزال الذي ضرب
المنطقه الجزء ناحيه النهر جرف معه قرابه
عشره منازل نجا سكانها باعجوبه من تحت
انقاضها فيما يقاوم هذا الجزء الانجرافات
التي سببها هذا الزلزال بعمق يزيد عن
ثلاثه مترات مخاوف اهالي هذه القريه لم
تتبدد بعد استمرار الهزات الارتداديه خوفا
من ان تشمل ما تبقى من اجزاء قريتهم عبد
القادر خربوش لقناتي العربيه والحدث من
قريه جسر الحديد على الحدود التركيه
السوريه
صدقه الولايات المتحده على بيع تايوان
ذخيره بقيمه 619 مليون دولار لطائراتها
المقاتله من طراز اف 16 تضم هذه الصفقه
التي يتوقع ان تثير استياء بكين 100 صاروخ
عالي السرعه مضاد للرادارات و200 صاروخ جو
جو متوسط المدى وقاذفات صواريخ واكدت
وزاره الدفاع الامريكيه ان هذه الصفقه
ستعزز قدره تايوان على ضمان الدفاع عن
مجالها الجوي والامن الاقليمي والتوافق في
العمليات مع الولايات المتحده
في الحرب على تطبيق تيك توك الصيني تقترب
امريكا من حسم الامر بعدما اقرت لجنه
الشؤون الخارجيه في مجلس النواب الامريكي
مشروع قانون يفرض على الاداره حظر تيك توك
او اي تطبيقات برمجيه تهدد الامن القومي
للولايات المتحده وفق رئيس اللجنه
النيابيه مايكل ماكول الذي اتهم تطبيق تيك
توك بمراقبه المستخدمين الامريكيين وجمع
بياناتهم لتفعيلها في الانشطه الخبيثه على
حد وصفه ويطلب التشريع من الاداره
الامريكيه فرض عقوبات بما في ذلك الحظر
على الشركات المصممه على اعطاء بيانات
مستخدمي تيك توك الى اي شخص اجنبي له صلات
بالحزب الشيوعي الصيني
وبالتوازي مع توتر العلاقات الفرنسيه
الايطاليه على خلفيه قضيه المهاجرين سيما
بعد غرق قارب قباله صوالح الايطاليا الاحد
وغرق اكثر من 60 مهاجرا وفقدان اخرين عادت
بوادر التوتر بين ايطاليا واليونان وزير
الداخليه الايطاليه اعتبر ان السياسات
الحدود اليونانيه الصارمه ربما تكون ساهمت
في قرارات ادت الى غرق قارب المهاجرين
وذلك من خلال دفعهم للهجره الى ايطاليا
بدلا من اليونان سيما وان اليونان اقرب
الى تركيا بكثير من جهتها نفت اليونان
الاتهامات بانها تصد المهاجرين وطالبي
اللجوء وقالت انها تعترض القوارب في البحر
لحمايه حدودها وحدود الاتحاد الاوروبي وفي
بيان اوضحت وزاره الهجره واللجوء
اليونانيه ان ما يجب فعله واغلاق جميع
منافذ العبور غير القانونيه عند نقطه
المغادره مشيره الى ان الارواح البشريه
ستظل تفقد في البحر المتوسط مع استمرار
مهربي البشر التربح من خلال وضع المهاجرين
في سفن غير صالحه للابحار
[موسيقى]
اطلقت شركه سبيس اكس صاروخا على متنه طاقم
الفضاء من ولايات فلوريدا الامريكيه تم
ارفاق اثنين من رواد الفضاء التابعين
لوكاله ناسا وراءت فضاء روسي ورائد فضاء
اخر من الامارات العربيه المتحده
بالكبسوله الموجوده فوق الصاروخ في رحله
الى محطه الفضاء الدوليه التابعه
بعد سنوات من قتال تنظيم داعش والتغلب
عليه تبقت معركه اخرى اكثر صعوبه هي
مواجهه ارثه الفكريه المتطرف وبقايا
مقاتليه وافراد عائلاته التي تتوزع في
مخيمات والسجون داخل سوريا والعراق
العربيه وضمن تغطيتها الخاصه دخلت اخطرت
تلك المخيمات مخيم الهول الذي تقيم فيه
زوجات مقاتلي داعش وابنائهم من العرب
والاجانب والتقت بهم ورصدت الاوضاع
الامنيه فيه بعد اكتشاف نشاط واضح لخلايا
التنظيم بداخله
لم تبقى له حصون ولا مدن ولكن لا يعتقد
كثيرون هنا في شمال شرق سوريا ان تنظيم
داعش زال يقولون انه باقي في مخيمات
والسجون و خلايا نائمه ورحله البحث عنه لا
تبدا الا من مخيم الهول
[موسيقى]
الدخول لمخيم رهول السدعه التنقل في مركبه
مصفحه وحراسه مسلحين من قوات حمايه المخيم
وهؤلاء لا ينتشرون عاده داخل المخيم بل
يكتفون بمراقبه البوابات وتسير دوريات لكن
جوله كهذه تثير مخاوفهم من هجوم مسلح او
حتى بحجاره
[موسيقى]
ثلاثه
اقسام غالبيتهم من عائله الدواعش قدمنا من
الباغوز ومناطق اخرى بدانا جولتنا من قسم
المهاجرات والاسم الذي يطلق على قسم زوجات
الدواعش غير السوريات او العراقيات
واطفالهن به خيام وسوق للملابس والخضر
من اين
تتحدثين قليلا
لن يكون الحديث مع الكثير منهن يسيرا رفضت
بعضهن الحديث
واخريات اعاقهن اللغه
متى اتيت الى هذا المخيم
الاقتراب من اخريات كان اسهل لكن الحديث
معهن كان ينعطف سريعا الى السماته في
الدفاع عن التنظيم
[موسيقى]
لا ترغب ام محمد وهكذا تسمي نفسها بالعوده
الى مصر فهي تعتقد ان ما تسميها دوره
الخلافه ستعود ترغبين بالعوده الى مصر
لكن اخريات ربما يئسنا ويامن فقط بان
يعدنا لبلدانهن
فعلا بالعوده للمغرب فعلا اكيد اليوم قبل
بكره
ندمتي على ذهابك اكيد ضروري يعني لازم نحن
نرجع بلدنا ما يضلوا اوضاعنا هيك يعني في
المخيم يعني انت شوفي يعني معروف الخيام
والوسخ وكل شيء يعني لازم يعني
ترحيله عائلتي داعش وتفكيك مخيم مسعا عبرت
عنه قوه سوريا الديمقراطيه التي طلبت
مرارا دولا باستلام رعاياها من عائله
التنظيم برايي الشخص انه اكثر من خمس سنين
او ست سنين احنا بحاجه لهم لحتى نفكك مخيم
الهول بالكامل لانه العدد كثير كبير العدد
ضخم انت عم تحكي عن 53 الف لاجئ ونازح
عندك العراقيين ما يقارب 27 الف عراقي
والسوريين اللي موجودين هن نسبتهم اكثر من
18 الف سوري اغلبيتهم هم من مناطق سيطره
الحكومه السوريه
وعندك قسم خاص بالاجانب اللي هنن
المهاجرات او اذا بدك تخلي المخيم منهم
هنبيعها بحاجه لقرارات دوليه صارمه حتى
انت تقدري تفكي المخيم وترجعي كل هدول
لبلدانهم
مهمه صعبه اذا فيما اداره المخيم وتامينه
يبدوان اصعب
كان في حمله امنيه للقوات حمايه المخيم
داخل المخيم خلال الحمد لله الامنيه تمضب
كميه كبيره من الاسلحه كمان تم القبض على
كثير من خلايا داعش
خطر بداوا ضحى بعد اكتشاف شبكه خنادق
وانفاق محفوره تحت الارض لتهريب السلاح
ومتطرفين واموال ساره بن عيشوبه العربيه
مخيم الهول في شمال شرق سوريا
نهايه النشره تذكير بابرز
العناوينز في مقابله خاصه مع العربيه وزير
الدفاع البريطاني يؤكد ان بلاده لن تمنح
اوكرانيا مقاتله طائفون
البحريه الامريكيه والبريطانيه تكشفان عن
مصادره شحنه اسلحه ايرانيه كانت متجهه الى
اليمن
دعم عسكري يستفد الصين امريكا تبيع تايوان
صواريخ وذخائر بقيمه 609 عشر مليون دولار
اجتماعي وزراء خارجيه العشرين في نيودلهي
الهند تؤكد وجود خلافات حاده تجاه الازمات
الدوليه
العربيه دوت ناتل المزيد من الاخبار
والتحليلات الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]